hello and welcome to this rapid game
2510 yep a little bit late here I
requested that game and then I was doing
something out there all subgroups the
game pop-up so let's see I'd hope for
interesting opening so I'm going for the
Greenfeld let's see it's as I mentioned
quite a bit not an opening that I have
ever played seriously tournament chess
fields dicey to me to play that but
let's see I mean not in general yeah
it's a perfectly fine opening but my
knowledge is quite limited so queen bee
three so let's see Nyjah 393 now
transposes to the yeah the so-called
Russian system okay she's trying to play
it without 93 it seems
okay so this is a transposition now um
yeah what do I know I know what lines
can be played a 69 a 696 Bishop g4 I
think recently I think they even tried
Bishop to e6 and after d5 just go back
something crazy like that okay I always
like to develop towards the center
possible so let's do 96
and well yeah I know that II five is a
line v 5590 form oops sorry and if you
take syd Knight g4 will get the pawn
back
k nitey fun if it takes twice on d4 I
think that's either c 6 p-8 but I don't
know okay he's not taking hmm so here I
probably have a choice I can capture on
each y3 and or play a more dynamic move
the field six comes into mind let's to
c6
now 90-84 ed for community for this
night takes d5 typical tactic okay it
takes that ok
yeah I think check this looks quite
logical and it seems that I get the poem
back if I just play C take the five now
let's see T I mean something like ctx he
takes 95 is just excellent for black
I've got the two bishops in an open
position and the bishop on g7 that's
just a very good piece I just wonder I
can also go rupee aid it's also not bad
let's do ruki 8 makes lots of sense
Bishop f4 I will play Knight age 5 and I
think white yeah it's falling apart
already that's not working at all yeti I
was thinking it takes on d5 let's take
hey just captures I was thinking maybe
some group do you want also yeah okay
I'll grab here rook t1 now there's 90 x
III and I'm just winning i believe so it
doesn't mind that position it looks
pretty pretty awful for white okay where
where'd you go Quincy five is just
provoking Bishop e3 and that black wants
to play anyway
hmm
you can also go to e6 then f 6m m kounye
five Bishop t2 Queen B 6 checa Bishop e3
and I don't have a particularly great
square for the Queen that's the only
thing that is a little bit off in my
position but it doesn't matter that much
okay so Q into d3
yeah do I play f6 here or not shots and
interesting an interesting question I
don't want to limit my g7 Bishop and I
caster can go b16a b6 and Bishop to be
seven know that that should be ok I also
a push of a 60 I was anticipating 24 now
i have f 6 as a possibility and wow now
I don't really I don't really see a
great move here for him yeah this moon
yeah just back to be seven I guess
that's the best diagonal anyway
hmm seems he wants to drag queens really
badly
hmm that's how to avoid
but how how exactly do I trade Queens I
try to play of 6cm
I tt7 loop t7
hmm not entirely sure I think maybe this
is this is actually good Rupert is seven
bishops e8 and then Bishop to e6 Bishop
c8 or I can also go to e4 okay then
maybe nine f7 ok let's do this and don't
argue anymore just play it who gave Sam
Bishop b5 drops material so he has to
yeah they're on our back and here i
think that rookie c8 next should
basically force the rook trade note that
the bishop one is six is always looking
at a two so okay
hmm i wonder if I can't play book see
ATM hmm i mean i can't play it i think
97 rookie some rookie 754 check king
King h1 I guess looks it to end it's
very difficult for him than to move
anything i also have bishop t5 common
and that's that's very good right let's
think about it Roxy 897 take sticks
check on before I can go to f1 but he
can sue is he cannot develop now look
ACA the squad oh yeah
if he takes the age with the Roku Bishop
takes I still prevent Bishop e3 and yeah
so he couldn't resist this I wonder if
ruby seven books it was better I don't
think so i'll check should give the
check
yeah and now I'm threatening Bishop t5v
and I'm absolutely absolutely not seeing
any defense he cannot move the bishop
you cannot move the beep on f5 maybe was
a move but then again be 55
it looks pretty bad so what now Bishop
Teague's is not so convincing
ya book check some chicks for the
discoveries route d7 check check and if
there's no made down
g two check check get a ton of checks
them
hmm I don't see a win for the yellow so
Bishop g2 let's check this again I hope
you're talking h2 Bishop b4 check maybe
hmm don't see a mate funny enough she
took his seven
hmm
Bishop g2 King edge to be sure before
chick can I win decisive material that
also is of course okay I think I'm
winning material there I don't see a
maid at the moment probably have just
two blind but this should win material
so check check here
I was thinking King g3 this Bishop F to
check and that should win material you
can go to h3 though and it looks more
than dangerous but don't see a window
King age three us the win
King 83 Bishop f5 chick King g3 Bishop F
to check king of three and running out
of checks
hmm
OOP she too is not threatening not
threatening much
yeah well he cannot really untangle but
where's the wind
should g1 this Bishop tutu something
crazy like that and there's no no way
forward huh remarkable and you have to
be commercials like group g2 op.7
everything hangs
look F to fork f3 is that doing much not
oh not oh not a lot that looks wrong
actually that looks wrong hmm Bishop f2
or threatening Bishop f5 maybe this is
the idea setting them up for a big
discovery yeah that's a decent idea
let's do that ideas Bishop f5 King on
the second Bishop e3 winning material
yeah that I could have played quicker
seems like a decent move kingi for I've
got h5 and wins h5 kingi 50 kh5 check
kingi 5s asking g7 hope that doesn't
really threaten anything just see that
hmm it threads rook c5 down okay here i
can play Bishop f5 check check don't see
anything better at the moon
but this at least wins big chunks of
material check check winning the bishop
on c1
yeah maybe there was some some eight but
I didn't see it
mmm so just we should be two or
something else i would like to keep that
pawn on d6
yeah let's keep it
maybe I can just okay here i think i'm
going back
tough to now keep the be porn yeah okay
but I thought Luke see three years I is
good or it says something better I can
also do this here ship g-form I can know
he escapes he escapes so let's not go
there check
so let's see okay Roxy to it's just the
repetition that doesn't really convince
yeah but I don't have anything great
here to be honest um if I repeat once
check on g4 King if for
maybe that's just when upon that
contract this and then Bishop deform
that is a pretty simple and good
continuation I just want to check the
Bishop g4 move just quickly Bishop g4
kini forma de check kinky five Bishop a
three that's pretty strong King d3
this doesn't look super clear my
intention was Bishop deform shifty for
weekly one group takes a two yeah that's
a simple way let's play it simple I
don't see a direct win at the moment so
I just take the upon root you one Bishop
g4 is easy so he has to go to key one I
think I'll check in that insert this
check and then take a two if he attacks
my f seven pole I can just play Bishop
b6 check and everything is covered okay
and it's not threatening much it's just
to check down so Bishop F to check king
of three Bishop g4 check kingi for you
to check mmm is that surgically a window
or not now it doesn't look let us look
Winnie actually check check rookie to
check king most eggs on you a Jew create
and Bishop age 40 be should be six a dad
wins you say a better move let's see I
mean I feel like I'm missing checkmates
here all the time but check maybe not
but it feels a lot like that I'm missing
stuff
yeah hmm I didn't consider this as i can
t cage fourth check which is probably
not not the end of the world I don't
have another I don't have a better
discovery but check taking the pawn
shouldn't be bad
and no he goes there okay so check
is there something good to know
something better than trading a rook
yeah at least it's a pretty safe way to
win the game okay well i will need to
play over the 25 10 game but you kind of
used to it you do it do it all the time
k bishop to the bishop is good on f2
anyway where it covers the b6 pawn the
only weakness okay thatthat's now pretty
easy i can take and kobe should be six
check winning the b3 poem and thats
that's the final little detail let's say
that makes the wind very easy because
now after this the only remaining
scenario was that I somehow lose the B
porn and he gets yeah he gets something
going with that but it's not happening
yeah now i just have captured the people
okay not rookie to please
can I was pretty sure that five here and
they're very nice if every nice setup
you have an end game with the two
bishops on f5 and c5 and they are both
nicely protected and they keep the King
completely passive can only go via d5 to
c4 and with no particular destination
after that I can just play Bishop g1 and
promote
just have to be careful not into run
into some cities stalemate say that
would be really cruel
again next move is Bishop reform
quite resigned okay so let's have a look
at this game that is a main line here
white normally goes p should be true i
think or t5 so there should be two as
one of the main news wear black choose
between Bishop g4 and the move I played
I know that this is a topical line at
the moment white however is usually
taking this and then this myth
threatening night txt five and then they
go d6 i believe the pretty pretty sharp
business like is hoping for is bishop
and this activity associated with that
yeah this i don't know i think c6 looks
pretty decent now but the real problem
is this by think this is just wrong
probably just taking something like this
this this is probably just equal ok so
she took it and played rupee eight
wanted to provoke the move f form as
this mostly weakens wide but it was
already a bit difficult to avoid this is
pretty bad straight away and moving the
night back it's not a real option you
can play like this now and we shouldn't
forget that black has a nice bishop am
and an open position with the bishop
fantastic okay this happened here and
now and then this is what i was thinking
the engine gives rook to d1 and
evaluates like a slightly better however
after
this I think he's in trouble yeah he had
to do that whoopty one that's relatively
best continuation and I went to e6 not a
happy square but the other squares um
weren't overly attractive either in here
I just give church and developed wide so
I couldn't really justify to play that
so Queenie six is good and now here yeah
okay I went b6 I wanted to develop the
Bishop Fisher basic sound interesting
yeah here I wasn't sure what to do the
engine gives rook a to be eight just
cover the bishop probably also good yeah
now f6 bye-bye stock fish but I think
this is not a not a bad continuation
it's funny the engine gives Bishop f6 is
even stronger because why does someone
out of moves okay so let's see how it
evaluates the chance change sacrifice
King f1 y aquí f1 is more critical this
losers this is more critical and the
engine gives a 5 with a slight edge to
black maybe a five I wouldn't plate own
a bishop c2 and sorry rook c2 probably
but a f5 makes an awful lot of sense
yeah we keep the pawn this is an
additional idea and I mean white cannot
develop now anyway if you do this this
looks very decent for for black this is
a mistake I think hmm the engine
actually hates rook c2 and once the
playgroup to d8 with the big advantage
probably yeah okay thread this Bishop c5
but isn't there or bishop f6 isn't there
some kind of defense okay you cannot
move the bishop you cannot move the jeep
on yeah moving the age pawn doesn't help
much what happens if items why it grabs
check check check that's made check who
amazing amazing yeah this is a mistake
King h1 with this also am rook e8 is
really better hmm amazing yeah anything
is white now the engine gives a chance
this and eight how can this be what is
this in the first place okay bow into
the bishop at sea okay the engine gives
this this back and equal full
compensation yeah yeah but I was hoping
I better who doesn't seem to be the case
and I I tend to trust the engineer
yeah that's good compensation but it is
not entirely clear yeah but this this
should lose them yeah this losses
straight away check and now the best is
to check on you for check which are
played and now Bishop f2 yeah I found
the best move there that's good here
Jeff 5 check should be one supposed to
be strong now just not a very human move
from but this is check but I could have
taken on between with the bishop but
check check check Jeff little chat check
check check took everything chat channel
schedule check out the winning end game
yeah this was um I'm again pretty
typical of a Greenfeld gone wrong for
wild can wear black and pretty quickly
opens up the center and gets this
central play going supported by the
bishop on g7 it was also not very nice
that he had to play a 4 and weaken
himself like that in this kind of
position now white some white has to
play on almost in a perfect way to keep
them keep the game going very difficult
to play in and around here I'm a lot
better already even though there were
moments where he could have could have
equalised okay thanks for watching